what I was thinking is I think I I think
the reason they're locking everything
down is because they're scared of unrest
like in New York
20% of NYPD is out and then we have this
story which I've mentioned several times
check this out
commercial burglaries sore since
coronavirus emergency measures New York
Post says that commercial burglary in
New York is up 75 percent Wow so let's
let's think about this we got 75 percent
that's a huge almost double yeah that's
crazy and that's that's not it's not
surprising but let's be real jeez
commercial burglary during a lockdown is
looting yeah absolutely
total looting definite so I wonder if
that's that's why the police have been
extremely harsh arresting random like
arresting people straight up like I see
you out there coming for you yeah
because unrest is a common man yeah and
you know there's stories from New York
and California that you know they've
reached the peak starting to slow down
the hospitals are starting to report
that you know it seems that things are
getting a little bit better on the the
kovat 19 front right you know so and
that's really not the issue the issue
now is we're so like the wheel has
stopped spinning for so long
that there's gonna be a point somewhere
that they run out of food it's already
happened in different places around the
world yep you know so in New York
food food I doubt we didn't talk about
food in a second I don't think this is
about food I think this is about just
social order breakdown well I wasn't
even it wasn't even really about food it
wasn't it's it's not the pandemic
anymore is what we have right here
exactly what I was trying to say it's
you know it's this kind of stuff it's
what happens after because the wheel has
stopped moving right yeah and that's
it's funny when I see all these memes
where they're like oh no the economy you
see the one Elon Musk tweeted what's
wrong like the earth and a comet ripped
straight through the earth the earth is
blowing up and there's an astronaut the
moon and he goes oh no the economy and
then someone posted under it the
dinosaurs looking up at the asteroids
slamming earth and they go oh no the
economy
it's a funny meme that's funny yeah but
it's also like people people really
don't get it when Trump comes out and
says the economy there's that other mean
remember that one where it's like the
is on a single track yeah and it's
headed for it's like you can stop the
trolley at any time but it would result
in a loss of profits for the trolley
company right it's really funny but what
people don't get man is that you got all
these people who have no access to the
economy anymore
yeah they're asking they're not just
gonna sit around right they're gonna go
out and they're in it I'm willing I'm
willing to bet we're gonna we will see I
mean you know man it's not a stupid
statement we're already seeing looting
they were already seeing it
police said 254 businesses have been
targeted between March 12th the day the
state of emergency order was issued and
March 31st this is up from a hundred and
forty five burglaries recorded for the
same time period last year what we are
seeing is that criminals are
specifically targeting cash businesses
supermarkets and bodegas dude yep what
do you what do you steal from a bodega
food fooling rats do things that they
really want this is not even the segment
we were gonna do on the food shortage
yeah I know and that's what they're
talking about but that makes sense
it makes sense that New York is is like
the where we're gonna see it all
happened first yep and here's what
people don't realize we got some good
news you mentioned it hospitalizations
in New York are way down intubation czar
the negative meaning they're taking
people off ventilators yeah more than
they're putting them on that's just New
York yeah we're there still some places
that haven't locked down at all some
cities there there are people out were
you know worshiping on Easter now I
fully respect First Amendment you know
you have a right to do so
yeah don't be surprised if in a couple
weeks you're gonna see a whole bunch
people get sick and then you're gonna
see a bunch of snooty people on Twitter
laughing going like you who told you so
yeah well you know what I think it's
gonna happen it's no coincidence that
it's about two weeks a little bit more
than two weeks since the hard lockdown
in New York now we're seeing
hospitalizations go down because the
incubation period was around two weeks
yeah so in that time period things got
really bad and ypd 20% we're calling off
all these stores were boarding up their
doors and windows what do you think
happens to the rest of the country now
as this as this thing starts sweeping
through it's going to happen a lot more
in a lot more places exactly yeah
looting is gonna get worse for sure what
are you doing in New York it's gonna get
worse what do you do
when he would he explained that question
let's it looks so so we live fairly
close to a bunch of our markets okay
like what would you do if a bunch of
people were you know showing up throwing
bricks and running around grabbing stuff
we just do outside your behind you and
push you out the door no I mean like
we're not gonna walk into the riot you
know what I mean no of course not
but like at what point do you say like I
don't you mean like you personally but
like for the people watching or
listening especially at what point do
you say like we gotta go yeah I'll tell
you what man I got a ton of emails
already mm-hmm weeks ago month ago
before I even lockdown they were like
dude you got that van you got to get in
you got to get out and I'm like well you
know hold on right nothing's happening
yet yeah now we're seeing looting is
this what I was thinking right yeah so I
had you know family and friend set me up
saying like I'm hearing it's getting
really really bad in New Jersey you know
I hope you're taking care and being safe
and I'm like yeah yeah we're fine we're
fine right yeah you know we went to the
store then we go to the Home Depot the
other day and they stopped us 30 feet in
front of the building and they're like
no no no no stop stop sup do what you
need masks and I was like we have to
have them like you can't come in without
a mask so now we're seeing like all
these other businesses are shuttered
they're taking things very serious
everybody was wearing a mask people took
people to come off when they got outside
so I kind of feel like I don't know
where the line is there's looting
happening in New York maybe we're seeing
the light at the end of the tunnel at
least for New York yeah everything's
good better but if we're already looking
at you know dramatic increase in
commercial burglaries they call it which
I just call looting is it is it you know
are we at the point where it's like this
is the warning we already heard the
president saying I'm gonna quarantine
these states maybe and then we were like
oh man what do we do and then you came
outside no I'm not gonna do it and we
went oh okay we were fine right was that
like the shot across the bow where it's
like heads up this is gonna happen yeah
maybe
and then we ignored it but I mean if 254
businesses were targeted when they did a
soft quarantine if they did a hard
quarantine guarantee that those numbers
will go up go up and I think so wouldn't
they go down if the police are forcing
people into their homes
I mean there's not that many police
officers Network
and then 20 yeah 20 percent are out and
a bunch of so there's Ovid already
there's like officially I think the
number is around 36,000 mm-hmm but
there's three shifts yeah
so at any one time you've got just over
10k right I think there's three shifts I
don't I don't know anything about the
place but for the people who are
interested in commercial burglaries when
you tell the world were shutting down
everything you're telling them no one's
gonna be at that business yep that
business is going to be closed maybe
that's why they're so our lands are
gonna go through you know exactly well
maybe that maybe that's why they're
calling it a burglary right now right
because it's locked and they're not
breaking in the traditional sense and
looting it as I'm looting and burglary
is I mean they're two sides of the same
coin
right right right yeah I would say in a
lockdown it's a loop yeah but my I get
it you know but my bigger question is
like I really don't think it we're gonna
get up right now after this show and
load up the van and dip out to like
middle of America like get away from the
chaos you know I mean mom mean if it's
gonna be a wave out away from New York
away from like where it hit the hardest
first if New York's already coming down
that means the rest of the country it's
gonna be a wave it's they're gonna have
spikes people don't know that they have
it you know so yeah it's almost to the
point where New York might not be that
bad of a place to be anymore
because it is locked up no I'm not
saying I want to be there I would not
want to be there you know but if the
supply chain doesn't get broken that's
really the key if stores still get their
stuff people can still go shopping and
get their usual food items and people
survive through you know the worst of
this then it's we're gonna come out of
it fine but if the supply chains get
broken it is broken in certain places in
New York no everywhere everywhere it
it's getting bad is it it's getting real
bad oh yeah dude feels like you know
some of my done well so we've been
looking at in a bunch of other countries
like in Italy for instance in Sicily
you've seen this coming so let me wrap
up this thought first and we'll jump
over the food one because we have this
ready to go I feel like you know Trump
comes out and says we're gonna
quarantine these three states
and we we at we had a conversation do we
stick around because we're in the South
we're not the North we're not worthy
we're not we're its it it would be silly
to say that if you're in the state
you're in the place that's it's it's not
that's not the case because you could be
in Connecticut and being one of the
worst-hit areas you can be in New
Hampshire it'd be totally fine you can
be in North Jersey and you are in it and
South Jersey's nothing's going on over
here so we were thinking like maybe
you'd be smart to leave also maybe it's
irresponsible but Trump wasn't gonna
quarantine where we were at he wanted to
do North Jersey like that whole area and
so that was the point where we were like
should we go now shot across the bow
they warned us we said no we're seeing
lootings go up we say no you know I
really don't think there's anything is
gonna convince us that now is the time
to go until it's too late I think I
really don't think anything will happen
where we're gonna be a lot of time to
get in the van and go head to the middle
of the country something I grew until
litter it's at the front door and we're
like oops
but I don't know you know but but that's
that's that's the conundrum so food
shortages I think are coming I
absolutely think so definitely they are
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you